[Music]
patron Q&A time house Heisenberg asks us
who would you say is the most
underappreciated filmmaker working day
my vote is for Stephen Chbosky who
masterfully made parts of being a wall
Pharaoh Oh as well as the movie wonder
which came out last year movie Natale
door and really recommends I really hope
it continues to make great films so more
people talk about him good choice
Stephen Chbosky is a great choice
I had this question before but we only
had a minute to answer it this course a
Martin Scorsese no one talks about the
guy ever 90 no rank my pick would have
to be Spike Jones this is a great Spike
Jones is a director that a lot of people
have definitely heard of but he's not
one of like the go-to directors that
people hail or like the greatest
considered or really praised when he's
giving us great films like being John
Malkovich a nap tation the thing that
happened with those films though I think
happened was the weirdness of Charlie
Kaufman subscripting outshine the
direction yeah yeah because especially
with like eternal sunshine coming out
following those films everyone really
just looked at those films was like
Charlie Kaufman's movies he you know and
you know you have things like wild
things that has a definite vision and a
definitely yeah impressive scope but
that is a bit more problematic to his
film like everybody on that movie but
then you got stuff like her beautiful
like her was like a beautiful weird film
and that's the thing that I really love
about Spike Jonze is he knows how to
find this right you know people are
always complaining about lack of
originality in Hollywood and Spike Jones
knows how to find this great blend
Charlie Kaufman he directed one movies
directed two movies in the Vettes
directorial debut people were like a
little too company you know he's got a
different director to hold him back a
little bit yeah yeah I mean I know it's
like follow up to one with the puppets
was animal ISA anomaly see and I'm ELISA
that was a great film spike jonze when
it comes to his direction he knows the
find this great balance of something
that could be appealing to mainstream
audiences but also give you so much
weirdness and absurdity that it's not a
turn-off sometimes you see these movies
at certain audience members
like a John well appreciate like that's
super weird and I John can appreciate
the super weird more than I can I
usually do I'm not as strongly
gravitated towards it spike jonze finds
that right blend of thrills enticement
backed with just bizarre dancin yeah
there's a warmth and a vibrance even if
it's a melancholy subject or something
he's got a good grip on yea certain
level of whimsy that's not too much but
that is quirky enough to kind of make
you twist up your eyebrows a little bit
and he if Spike Jonze kind of reminds me
of Michel Gondry in certain ways too who
is also somewhat of an underrated
filmmaker I guess but like the way in
which he will do features and then he'll
jump over into these things he'll do
like a strange music video or a perfume
ad or just recently he did this Apple
home commercial and each one features
these like crazy
both dances and visual tricks that are
happening and you're sitting there going
what how did you do this not only got a
great grip on tone but also he seems
like an innovator especially when he
gets to do the more out there the moral
side project type of things coming up
with answers for this I was kind of
jealous when you said Spike Jonze
because like the perfect answer to this
question I feel like he is the perfect
one because because he has a consistency
yes I feel like Michele gondry doesn't
really have a strong of a consistency I
mean there's an argument to be made
there but in terms of critics and for
audiences both responding incredibly
well in terms of likability to the
movies and yet it's not really praised
that much in terms of like when we
recognize like directors that we love
Spike Jonze is wildly consistent I came
up with a few I came up with like a list
trying to suss this out and what I
thought might be alright was Richard
Linklater has a great track record of
films has a really assured grip on
filmmaking and like he's been lauda Din
stuff like I feel like Linklater is like
rated he's like right in the middle
Richard Linklater is a guy who you
looked through his catalogue and they're
like tons of really great films people
only kind of talked about a couple of
them but he's made films on multiple
levels he's done experimental films and
stuff like boyhood where it's like you
know building a film over a life that
he'll do stuff like School of Rock which
is equally you know lovable and great
but it's you know a Jack Black movie the
book
for sunrise before sunset before
midnight those movies are terrific
that's a terrific trilogy through and
through that is you know both really a
shirt on his end but also really
collaborative like he's a he's a
director who I feel like more people
oughta you know bring up or whatever the
other names I had I kind of you touched
on that was there aren't enough films I
really like current Kusama but she's
only made like a handful of films thus
far as I know what I mean the invitation
which came out a couple years ago now
which I really love that movie and I got
some you know buzzes towards the end of
that year but that was like my favorite
movie that year nobody likes Jennifer's
body but I really like Jennifer's body
actually the only like black mark on her
track record is Aeon Flux I guess I feel
like that's probably not her fault
especially the time at which it was me
scale on which was made Rob Zombie just
for me sure just for me the ratio to
which I enjoy his films as versus the
way nobody else does I feel like he's
severely underrated I just watched the
gift so joel edgerton highly underrated
director people aren't still talking
about that one movie very skilled same
kind of goes for like Neill Blomkamp I
feel like that guy's got a lot of
terrific tools think it's a fair it's a
fair one Neill Blomkamp
I feel like they're the thing is he's
kind of in terms of like people being
receptive to his work yeah it's like
he's falling out of favors going over
yeah because people love district 9 I
like Elysium a lot dislikes of ice is
better yeah and then chappie you got to
be most very stone like these kind of
claiming his own space with the shorts
and stuff now and and I think that's
cool but you know I always wish he got a
little more love but but Spike Jones at
least for this for the purest answer to
this question I feel like Spike Jones or
maybe a Richard Linklater pretty good
well thanks for the question House
Heisenberg our very first patron ever I
will never forget that